for the longest time I sought the height
of perfection I dreamt of giving my
heart and soul to battle an unstoppable
adversary I'm a lucky man I'm thankful
for everything that led me to this point
that led me to you hello and welcome to
Hunter hunter 101 series that breaks
down everyone and everything in the
Hunter hunter world today we are going
to be launching an investigation into a
man who was once called most powerful
men user in the world
Isaac netter Oh Isaac Metro is a
seemingly joyous and surprisingly
muscular centenarian who was first
introduced in the series during the
hunter exam arc as the 12th chairman of
the hunter Association during this
introduction netra was presented as an
eccentric elder a very mischievous
person to whom any other individuals
would characterize as straddling the
borders of insanity however in reality
this was butter shell masking an
extraordinarily complex character both
selfish and selfless an arbiter of order
as well as an agent of chaos it was
capable of great good and great evil and
to really attain a solid understanding
of nature oh we need to travel back in
time to when he was the comparatively
youthful age of 46 during this time net
Row ascended into the mountains in order
to train his body and mind here he would
develop a daily ritual with performing
10,000 punches to show his gratitude
towards martial arts a feat that would
take him a total of 18 hours to complete
on the very first day resulting in a
tower collapsing from sheer exhaustion
only to awaken the next day and repeat
the offering after two years had passed
now to her found that he was able to
complete the ritual before the Sun had
even set and by the time he reached the
age of fifty nattara was able to offer
10,000 punches within a mere hour and
with all of his newfound free time nets
row delve deep into prayer that
eventually led him to achieving a state
of enlightenment by the time he
descended from the mountains net row had
transcended the natural limits of
humanity acquiring an ability to strike
faster than the speed of sound and
developing a legion of followers begging
to be trained by him resulting in the
founding of the Shingen Review School of
kung-fu but as for why Nero engaged in
this 4-year endeavor to begin with well
to put it simply it's because Netru
lived for the pursuit of power and the
thrill of challenge Ness row held
immense pride for his own
accomplishments
although he was a far from benevolent
martial arts master as he harbored
absolutely no respect or tolerance for
the week but after acquiring the
pinnacle of power
rose-gold was simplified to the mere act
of finding a worthy adversary in this
pursuit he actively welcomed challenges
at his dojo although each and every one
of them would be defeated
eventually netra would grow tired of
searching for a challenge in the known
world and decided to embark on two
expeditions to the dark continent a
colossal area of the world containing
incredibly powerful extinction-level
threats that is forbidden to the general
public and even members of the hunters
Association however despite the
unrivaled danger presented by this
location Metro would leave unsatisfied
because the Dark Continent did not
contain the opponent he was looking for
and the only victory to be games there
was survival returning to the realm of
humanity Ness wrote continued his
fruitless search and in the process he
would come to be elected as the 12th
chairman of the hunter Association and
in this new position he adopted a great
sense of leadership becoming an
unwavering symbol of strength of the
Association however he did implement
many controversial actions such as
appointing Paris tin hill as
vice-chairman purely for the perplexing
reason that net errol was entirely
incapable of getting along with him and
so as a result under net rows watchful
eye no less Harriston began a career of
consistently undermining the integrity
of the Association as well as networked
himself but of course as head of the
Association networ was also charged with
overseeing the hunter exam a notoriously
brutal endeavor when notorious complete
lack of empathy was demonstrated
firsthand as he willingly propagated a
system based on weeding out unfit
candidates via the art of frequent
fatalities although it would be during
one of these exams that we would first
encounter Netra through gon and killua
where he demonstrated his more
mischievous side by offering to allow
them to become hunters directly should
they be able to complete the simple task
of taking a bowl from him
furthermore nestor also decided to
conduct this challenge without using his
right arm or his left leg Kilowog with
his extensive combat experience very
quickly realized that they had
absolutely no chance and refused to
participate any further however the more
how shall we put this basic gone refused
to back down until he forced him to use
his right hand much to the amusement of
Netra and during the final phase of the
exam Neuros sense of respect for
strength would be on full display in the
form of a bracket he crafted for a
rather intriguing combat tournament
using natural logic each combatant would
only have to win one round to attain the
Hondas license while SaLuSa
would advance not only that but those
who had performed well in the exam up
until this point were given more
opportunities to pass whereas those who
hadn't were given two chances at most in
essence crafting a tournament that
that played out exactly according to
plan only one individual ie the very
weakest would have lost however not
every decision made by nature Oh was
committed in order to say t8a twisted
desire for challenge as he frequently
laid down decrees in the interest of the
public and hunter-safety
one of which was lobbying the v5 to
forbid travel to the Dark Continent and
there were even moments during the
Chimera ant arc when net were
prioritized achieving a particular goal
over pursuing personal challenges
speaking of it would not be until the
Chimera talked that the full extent of
metros absurd abilities would be
revealed as in response to the threat
presented by the Chimera ant snare -
reformed an extermination team charged
with the lofty task of saving humanity
from extinction
the most important act of which was
killing the ant king Maron a task that
would fall to netter himself now
generally this wouldn't be such a big
ask however it should be noted that
prior to the invasion of the palace
natura asked a chimera ant by the name
of cult to compare his aura to that of
marijuana - which Colt replied that
notorious power was nowhere near enough
to combat the ant king sparking a wild
fire of challenge within net arou
because after what had felt like an
eternity
Neto had finally found someone who he
was able to fight all-out against and in
the preceding battle against marijuana
netra aptly demonstrated he was once
called the strongest nen user in the
world at this point it should be noted
that Metro is an enhancer when it comes
to nen however he also possesses an
extraordinary mastery over emission and
manipulation and in fact it is through a
combination of these f4 mention types
the Metro developed his strongest
ability the 100 type Guanyin Bodhisattva
through this abilitynet ro is able to
emit a gigantic statue of guanyin the
arms of which he can control by clasping
his hands together mimicking in prayer
after this Metro is then able to select
one of 100 different motions each of
which correspond to one of the statues
hands now in the possession of almost
anybody else this ability would be
prohibitively served to use in any way
effectively however in the hands of
Metro a man who at the very least over
half a century ago mastered the art
offering ten thousand punches within an
hour this ability was devastating
with Metro managing to complete a full
attack process in less than 0.1 of a
second furthermore nasara even possessed
one other ultimate attack known as zero
hand which has the statue of guanyin
appear behind an opponent to clasp them
tightly with both hands and then
mercilessly fire every last bit of
Metro's raw ore at them and Whitney's
101 hands Netta rose attack combination
our seemingly infinite although even
with all of that said not even this was
enough to conquer the ant king after
several exchanges marijuana juice net
rose unconscious bias for using certain
combinations and ended up severing
metros right leg and shortly after that
his left arm to top it all off at this
point marijuana was completely unscathed
even after being struck by a true zero
hand ability this wasn't overwhelming
impossible situation that Neto had never
encountered and was certain to result in
his death and to his great credit
despite his up until now unparalleled
strength natural understood that this
was indeed a possibility and the
potential of which even excited him
further as he stood to the challenge
that he had sought out his entire life
and with the assistance of an explosive
known as the poor man's rose which had
been implanted into his body natural
choice to end his life conveying one
last message of humanity's potential for
cruelty and malice by eradicating
marijuana as well as two of his royal
guards and as collateral damage and
innocent civilian named coma me so I
said in the beginning that network could
be described as an extraordinarily
complex character for its selfish and
selfless an arbiter of order and an
agent of chaos capable of great good and
great evil and as it turns out there is
another word for that sort of complexity
the word that is difficult to apply to
network having now understood exactly
how he was able to transcend himself but
that word is human so more fun facts
about Isaac natural following the
Chimera ant arc it was revealed that
nets were not only understood the
possibility but also even predicted his
death at the hands of marijuana and
recorded a video detailing the process
to be used for the election of the next
chairman of the hunter Association
despite Nessarose notoriety he himself
has admitted that there are at least
four to five nen users in the world who
are equal to or stronger than he however
this does not necessarily mean that
these individuals are stronger than him
the network himself has a tendency to
publicly downplay his own power making
him a very unreliable source on the
topic at some stage during his life
never found the time to have a child who
is rather creatively named beyond
natural the man who follows in his
father's footsteps so closely that he
has even secretly travelled to the Dark
Continent and plans on doing so once
again
Metro also seems to have quite a strong
history with the zolteck family having
been good friends with zigge zoldak as
well as having allegedly been the only
one to fight against Maha zoldak and
live furthermore he is on very familiar
terms with Zeno zoldak and plus of
course he even encountered kill
during the 280 7th hunter exam one of
notorious most notable lines in the
series is him claiming that he had
dreamt of giving his heart and soul to
battle an unstoppable adversary and in
the end he did achieve this dream by
focusing all of his aura into the zero
hand blast thus giving his soul and with
his final act of piercing his heart to
end his life to activate the poor man's
wearisome despite the fact that the 100
type Guan Yin Bodhisattva is considered
to be Network our fillet his natural nan
affinity of enhancement does not appear
to be tapped in its use at least not on
a surface level anyway it has been
theorized that the enhancement does play
a role in regards to natural using it to
accelerate his speed in reflexes
although that is entirely speculation at
the time of this recording and finally a
truly useless fact when Metro was toying
with gone and kilowatt during the hunter
exam he was able to fend them off
without using his right arm or left leg
and those just so happened to be the two
of them that he was left with after his
encounter with marijuana but that pretty
much does it for Isaac Natura if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps spot
this channel an incredible amount if
you'd like to join the fun at anytime
then please do head over to my disco
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured on
the next hunter hunter 101
Oh